depleted by drought last Summer's heat
waves are still biting this time into
Food Supplies having much less water in
the bank at this time of year is means
that we've had to reduce our irrigated
cropping area by 25 for this next to
this next growing season Andrews scaled
back his vegetable crops whether the
farmers doing the same amid warnings of
more shortages to come the cost of
production of increased uh almost
exponentially which is which is a
massive challenge you know many
businesses just can't bear that extra
cost and they just can't take that risk
so we're really calling on the the
retailers to to pay what it at least
what it costs to produce plus some form
of margin to make it more sustainable
and and to encourage us to continue to
produce food in the UK severe weather
overseas is already disrupting supplies
supermarkets are rationing vegetables
like cucumbers and tomatoes prompting
this from the environment secretary it's
important to make sure that we cherish
the specialisms that we have in this
country a lot of people would be eating
termites right now rather than thinking
necessarily about aspects of lettuce and
and tomatoes and so a run on turnips
with some shops sold out and more people
coming to smaller Grocers
we've got three supermarkets main
supermarkets one of them of which I've
used quite a lot like we're just out of
everything and the stuff they had was
just scraps I would always rather shop
locally I think it's good that local
places support local businesses so yeah
I would rather have good quality stuff
from local places rather than
supermarkets Spanish tomatoes and
peppers are plentiful here but wholesale
prices have rocketed wholesale cost on
things like salad crops even onions I
would say they've gone up by at least
minimum of 80 percent and that is across
the board the government says the UK has
a highly resilient food supply chain
well equipped to deal with disruption
but Farmers say it goes deeper
behind all this multiple factors farmers
face labor shortages high energy costs
the impacts of climate change as well as
Global political turmoil but what's
becoming ever more clear is that amid a
volatile environment particularly down
to the Ukraine war and covered Supply
chains food security has never been more
important
shortages could last weeks while farmers
are hoping at least for a drought-free
summer Adele Robinson Sky News Suffolk